.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Das sind Christoph Spörris
letzte Minuten in Freiheit.
Tschüss.
Heute muss er ins Gefängnis.
Zurück lässt er
seine Frau und seine Kinder.
Was sagten Sie Ihrer Frau?
Dass ich sie liebe und sie
gut auf die Kinder aufpassen soll.
Konnten Sie sich gut
von den Kindern verabschieden?
Ja.
So. Packen wir es an.
Christoph Spörri tritt heute
seine vierjährige Haftstrafe
im Regionalgefängnis Bern an.
Der ehemalige DJ wurde
wegen Anstiftung zu Brandstiftung
und versuchtem
Versicherungsbetrug verurteilt.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Frühmorgens
bei der Familie Spörri in Bern.
(Flüsternd) Kyano.
Du musst langsam aufstehen,
Schätzchen.
Hey, wir haben Besuch.
Christoph Spörri
weckt den neunjährigen Kyano.
Also, komm.
Hm? Hallo.
Deymien. Aufstehen.
- Hm?
Auch für den 13-jährigen Deymien
ist es Zeit zum Aufstehen.
Macht ihr euch ready?
- Mhm.
Eigentlich müsste ihr Vater
in wenigen Wochen ins Gefängnis.
Doch es kommt anders.
Wenn ich gewisse Dinge mache,
denke ich manchmal daran,
wie es sein wird,
wenn ich alles allein machen muss.
Da wird einiges auf mich zukommen.
Wenn man Unterstützung hat,
auch bei der Betreuung der Kinder,
und immer alles zusammen macht ...
Mein Mann
unterstützt mich immer super.
Bis heute sagt Christoph Spörri,
dass er nichts mit der Brandstiftung
von 2012 zu tun habe.
Doch alle Instanzen
sprachen ihn schuldig.
Man macht sich täglich Gedanken.
Das schwirrt
schon seit Jahren im Kopf rum.
Ich musste lernen, damit zu leben.
Ich bin nicht einer,
der den Kopf in den Boden steckt
und sagt: "Jetzt mag ich nicht mehr.
Jetzt ist fertig."
"Mein Leben ist vorbei."
Ich bin eher der Typ, der wieder
aufsteht, wenn er am Boden liegt.
Das ist jetzt wieder der Fall.
Es ist nicht das erste Mal, dass ich
wieder von unten beginnen muss.
Aber ich werde es
auch dieses Mal schaffen.
Hier sind eure Geburtstagsmuffins.
- Ich gehe kurz ohne Jacke.
Viel Spass.
Einen schönen Tag.
- Ich komme gleich wieder.
Ich hoffe, sie sind lecker.
- Boah ...
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
Die Familienverhältnisse
sind nicht einfach:
Der ältere Sohn
hat eine andere Mutter.
Er will aber bei seinem Vater,
Christoph Spörri, bleiben.
Ein Sorgerechtsstreit läuft.
Und der Vater muss ins Gefängnis.
Das ist
eine schwierige Situation für uns.
Wir haben schon einiges
zusammen durchgestanden.
Wir werden auch das durchstehen.
Hat sich Ihre Beziehung
dadurch verändert,
dass Ihr Mann
nun ein verurteilter Straftäter ist?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ich kenne meinen Mann sehr gut, weil
wir schon so lange zusammen sind.
Deshalb weiss ich auch Dinge,
die andere nicht wissen.
Daher bin ich überzeugt,
dass mein Mann
nichts mit dem Fall zu tun hat.
Darum kann ich mich ihm gegenüber
auch so verhalten ...
Ja, für mich ist er kein Verbrecher.
Und selbst wenn er
etwas damit zu tun hatte:
Es gibt Menschen,
die Fehler machen in ihrem Leben.
Auch in solchen Situationen
sollte man zueinanderstehen können.
Der Kriminalfall um ihren Mann
beginnt 2012.
Christoph Spörri
hat damals Kreditkartenschulden
und mehrere Betreibungen sind hängig.
Am 1. Mai 2012 brennt
in Ostermundigen eine Lagerhalle.
Christoph Spörri ist damals DJ und
lagert hier seine Plattensammlung.
Der Brand zerstört sie komplett.
Die Platten sind aber versichert:
für 200'000 Fr.
Am nächsten Morgen wollte ich
etwas holen, und da sah ich es.
Das weiss ich noch.
Das war ein bitterer Anblick.
Die Ermittlungen zeigen:
Zwei Männer legten den Brand
und verletzten sich dabei.
Brisant: Den einen Brandstifter
kennt Christoph Spörri persönlich.
Er war damals Spörris Fitnesstrainer.
Dieser vergoss
zusammen mit seinem Komplizen
Motorenbenzin im Schallplattenlager.
Gegen Christoph Spörri
wird bald ein Verfahren eröffnet.
Der Verdacht:
Er habe den Brand in Auftrag gegeben,
um die Versicherungssumme
zu kassieren.
Ich nahm das nicht so ernst.
Ich war damals so erfolgreich,
dass ich fand:
"Sorry, für 200'000 Fr.
würde sich das nicht lohnen."
Also, sicher nicht.
Ich wusste es,
aber ich verdrängte es.
Das klingt vielleicht komisch,
aber wir waren sehr entspannt
und hatten auch keine Angst,
dass uns etwas passieren würde.
Er war ...
Die zwei anderen,
die am Brand beteiligt waren ...
... waren ja damals
schon mal in Haft.
Sie wurden befragt und sagten nie,
dass mein Mann
etwas damit zu tun hatte.
Ja ... Deshalb gab es da nichts ...
... wovor wir
hätten Angst haben müssen.
Doch viereinhalb Jahre nach dem Brand
erhebt der Staatsanwalt Anklage
gegen die zwei Brandstifter
und Christoph Spörri.
Er wird
wegen Anstiftung zur Brandstiftung,
versuchtem Versicherungsbetrug
und weiteren Delikten angeklagt.
Ja, das überraschte mich.
Das überraschte uns.
Die Anklageschrift,
die wir erhielten ...
Da stand ja nichts drin.
Da stand nichts
von irgendwelchen Beweisen,
die das unterstützen,
was sie ihm vorwerfen.
Bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt
sagte der Brandstifter,
den Spörri gut kannte,
dass nicht Christoph Spörri
den Auftrag gegeben habe,
sondern der Vermieter
der zerstörten Lagerhalle.
Dieser erhielt von der Versicherung
über 60'000 Fr.
Das Strafverfahren gegen ihn
wurde aber eingestellt.
Am Prozess in Bern
dann die grosse Überraschung:
Beide Brandstifter
erzählen plötzlich,
Christoph Spörri
habe den Auftrag gegeben.
Wir standen alle unter Schock -
auch mein Anwalt.
Von 2012-2016 sagten sie nie,
dass ich das gewesen sei.
Der Indizienprozess um
den bekannten DJ wirft hohe Wellen.
Es geht um den Aufstieg und Fall
des Plattenauflegers Christopher S.
Im November 2016 das Urteil:
sechs Jahre Haft,
weil der DJ, laut den Richtern,
seine Plattensammlung
in Brand stecken liess.
Man steht einfach unter ...
Man ist in einem Schockzustand.
Man macht sich danach ...
Man macht sich keine Gedanken.
Man ist einfach leer.
Man denkt, das sei ein Witz und der
dort vorne wolle einen verarschen.
Also, wirklich.
Ich sehe immer noch
das triumphierende Lächeln
des Staatsanwalts.
Er hatte das gefordert.
Gut, er hatte 72 Monate gefordert.
Er kriegte seine sechs Jahre,
was eher unüblich ist.
Meistens gehen die Richter
weit unter
die Forderungen der Staatsanwälte.
Anscheinend
wollte man ein Exempel statuieren.
Ich war gefühllos und ...
... erschüttert.
Und ...
Das Schlimmste ...
Die schlimmste Erinnerung, die mir
von der Urteilsverkündung bleibt ...
Das Schlimmste, was mir bleibt ...
Die "Basler Zeitung"
gab das damals auch so wieder.
Das Schlimmste war,
dass der Richter sagte:
"In dieser Sache wird
man die Wahrheit nie herausfinden."
"Es könnte so oder so gewesen sein,
aber mit grösster Wahrscheinlichkeit
war es Herr Spörri,
der den Auftrag gegeben hat."
Diese Worte waren noch so lange
in meinem Kopf drin.
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass so etwas passieren könnte.
Zieht er den Kopf noch aus der
Schlinge oder muss er ins Gefängnis?
Der ehemalige Star-DJ Christopher S.
kämpft ab heute vor dem Obergericht
für seine Freiheit.
Doch auch das Obergericht
verurteilt ihn
zu vier Jahren Freiheitsstrafe.
Im Urteil steht:
Spörris Betreibungen
in der Höhe von über 132'000 Fr.
und ein Gesamtschuldenbetrag
von 170'000 Fr.
seien ein plausibles Motiv
für einen Versicherungsbetrug.
Christoph Spörri gibt nicht auf
und
zieht den Fall vor das Bundesgericht.
Ohne Erfolg:
Das Gericht lehnt
in seinem Urteil die Beschwerde ab.
Es hält aber fest, dass insgesamt
auch Gründe vorliegen könnten,
welche ein alternatives Tatgeschehen
mit einer anderen Täterschaft
möglich erscheinen lassen.
Doch Spörri bleibt verurteilt.
Vamos, vamos.
Noch ist Christoph Spörri
nicht im Gefängnis
und hat Zeit für einen Spaziergang
mit seiner Frau und den Hunden.
Seit 27 Jahren sind Christoph
und Tina Spörri zusammen -
mit einem kurzen Unterbruch.
Funkte es sofort?
- Nein, gar nicht.
Also, bei mir nicht.
Was ich immer so lustig finde:
Damals kostete ein Getränk,
ein Mineral, 10 Fr.
Er lud mich zu einem Getränk ein.
Dann fragte er mich, ob wir
sonst mal etwas trinken gehen.
Ich wollte eigentlich nicht,
aber ich dachte:
"Wenn er 10 Fr.
für ein Getränk ausgegeben hat,
kann ich jetzt nicht sagen,
dass ich nicht noch mal
etwas mit ihm trinken möchte."
Und dann heiratete sie diesen Vogel.
Ah schau, da gibt es Leckerli.
- Genau.
Siehst du?
* Lachen *
Unser Hund
gehorcht anderen besser als uns.
Nur, weil es Leckerli gibt.
- So ist es.
Geniessen Sie die Freiheit noch mehr,
wenn Sie in der Natur sind,
weil die ja bald für eine Weile
zu Ende sein wird?
Ich bin
ein freiheitsliebender Mensch.
Ich bin auch tagsüber
nicht viel zu Hause.
Wenn meine Frau arbeitet
und die Kinder in der Schule sind,
bin ich nicht zu Hause,
sondern draussen.
D.h., ich gehe in die Stadt,
gehe mit den Hunden
in mein Lieblingslokal ...
Ich bin gerne draussen.
Es wird hart sein.
Deshalb heisst es Freiheitsentzug.
Das wird das Härteste für mich.
Ah, dort.
Hey, Bro.
- Ich bringe die Kameras.
Sali, Paulo.
- Hoi. Wie geht's?
Ich komme am Freitag oder Samstag.
Samstag?
Ja? Also, ist gut.
- Ja.
Tschüss, Bro. Tschüss.
Tschau.
Bis am ... Kommst du am Samstag?
- Ja.
Ich kenne fast die ganze Stadt.
Was sagte ein Journalist kürzlich?
Ich sei eines
der wenigen Urgesteine in Bern.
Ein Original.
Das kann man sehen, wie man will.
Für mich ist es ein Kompliment.
Jungs, kennt ihr das noch?
Was ist das?
Eine CD.
Das kennt die heutige Jugend
nicht mehr.
Christoph Spörri bereitet sich
nach einer langen DJ-Pause
auf seinen DJ-Auftritt
als Christopher S. vor.
Sind das alles deine CDs?
- Ja.
So wie ich sie vor
dreieinhalb Jahren sortiert habe.
Jetzt steigt die Nervosität langsam.
Aber das gehört zu einem Künstler.
Wenn die Nervosität nicht mehr
da ist und das Kribbeln nicht kommt,
dann ist Ende Feuer.
Ehefrau Tina
begleitet ihren Mann in den Club.
Es wird der letzte Auftritt
ihres Mannes als DJ sein,
bevor er ins Gefängnis geht.
Die Kinder
bleiben heute allein zu Hause.
* Man hört Musik aus dem Club. *
Fast jeder hier im Berner Club
Mad Wallstreet kennt ihn:
DJ Christopher S.
# Christopher S.
is in the megamix right now.
# Let's put some energy
in this place, place, place, place.
# Put your hands up in the air
and clap with me.
# Ten, nine, eight, seven,
six, five, four, three, two -
# let's get ready to rumble.
* Laute Technomusik *
Christopher S.
setzt ab 2001 voll auf die Musik:
sowohl als DJ, wie auch als
Musikproduzent und mit eigenem Label.
Und dies mit Erfolg.
Medienauftritte mit seiner Familie,
200 DJ-Auftritte pro Jahr,
ein Leben in Saus und Braus.
Seine insgesamt 19 CD-Compilations
erreichten z.T. Topplatzierungen
in der Schweizer Hitparade.
* Laute Technomusik *
Es ist wirklich geil.
Ich bin wieder mal voll im Flow.
Von mir aus könnte ich 2 Std.
weiterspielen. Das ist cool.
# Everybody
put your hands in the air.
* Technomusik mit starkem Bass, über-
lagert von nachdenklichen Klängen *
Heute feiert Christoph Spörri
sich und seine Musik.
Doch sein Leben auf der Überholspur
ist längst vorbei:
Geldprobleme, ein Privatkonkurs
und die Freiheitsstrafe
prägen sein Leben seit Jahren.
Und bald soll er die Haftstrafe
von vier Jahren antreten.
"Aufgebot und Vollzugsverfügung:
Sehr geehrter Herr Spörri,
wir bieten Sie auf,
Ihre Strafe wie folgt anzutreten:
Montag, 3.2.2020, vor 10 Uhr
vormittags, Regionalgefängnis Bern."
Wie ist es für Sie, dass Sie
tatsächlich ins Gefängnis müssen?
Ja, das ist hart.
Ich habe natürlich damit gerechnet.
Aber als ich nun
diesen Brief erhalten habe ...
Das wühlt einen wieder auf.
Ich habe das überflogen.
Ich kenne das Datum ja.
Ja, das ist heavy.
Ja. Mehr gibt es nicht zu sagen.
Das wünsche ich niemandem.
Doch anstatt im Gefängnis
sitzt er Mitte Mai 2020
beim Coiffeur.
Zeit für die Bartpflege -
kurz nach dem coronabedingten
Shutdown in der Schweiz.
Ich rannte
nicht als Erstes zum Coiffeur.
Ich liess mir eh die Haare wachsen,
deshalb passte es perfekt.
Den Kindern
schnitten wir die Haare zu Hause.
Aber man achtet schon darauf,
in dieser ganzen Zeit.
Aber das war immer so.
Ich finde es wichtig,
sich Sorge zu tragen.
Christoph Spörri
ist noch in Freiheit.
Er stellte ein Gesuch,
um seinen Haftantritt zu verschieben,
bis der Sorgerechtsstreit um
seinen älteren Sohn entschieden ist.
Die Berner Behörden
gewährten ihm einen Aufschub.
Und dann spielte ihm
die Coronapandemie in die Hände:
Um Ansteckungen in Gefängnissen
zu verhindern,
müssen verurteilte Personen,
von denen
keine unmittelbare Gefahr ausgeht,
ihre Haftstrafe noch nicht antreten.
Deshalb kann Christoph Spörri
das Regionalgefängnis Bern
noch von aussen betrachten.
Ich habe ein Déjà-vu.
Meine Frau arbeitete hier nebenan.
Ich wartete hier jeweils auf sie
und hörte dann, wie die in U-Haft
an die Fenster klopften.
Es läuft so:
Man rückt ein, hat ein Gespräch,
kriegt den Vollzugsplan und schaut,
dass man möglichst schnell rauskommt
und es weitergeht.
Ein paar Jahre hier drin zu sein, in
U-Haft oder so, ist echt nicht cool.
Ich kenne noch eine Person,
die hier arbeitet und sagte,
wenn ich komme,
gebe es Kaffee und Kuchen.
Ja.
Aber jetzt ist es so. Fertig.
Ich habe genug durchgemacht
und alles erlebt in meinem Leben.
Doch Spörris kämpfen weiter
gegen die Gefängnisstrafe,
trotz Bundesgerichtsentscheid.
Sie reichen Beschwerde
beim Europäischen Gerichtshof
für Menschenrechte
in Strassburg ein:
Laut Spörris sei der Grundsatz
"im Zweifel für den Angeklagten"
verletzt worden.
- Ich sagte von Anfang an:
"Ich gehe bis aufs Letzte."
Ich will alles versucht haben.
Ich kann nicht einfach sagen,
es sei so,
weil das Bundesgericht
es so bestimmt hat.
Ich habe nicht die typische ...
Es soll sich
niemand angegriffen fühlen,
aber ich habe nicht
die typische Schweizer Mentalität
und akzeptiere das einfach so.
Ich muss es akzeptieren,
kann es aber nicht akzeptieren.
Sie haben ja nichts.
Christoph Spörri reichte auch bei
den Berner Behörden ein Gesuch ein:
Er möchte seine Strafe
nicht im Gefängnis, sondern zu Hause,
mit einer elektronischen Fussfessel,
verbüssen.
Das wäre ein Novum bei mir.
Eigentlich kann man Fussfesseln
nur bis zwölf Monate erhalten.
Aber warum nicht ein Novum?
Man gibt die Fussfesseln
eh zu wenig raus.
Also, das wurde ja getestet
und das funktioniert.
Und ich will ja nicht fliehen.
Wir - und v.a. er -
haben schon eine gewisse Strafe ...
Er hat irgendwie schon
eine gewisse Strafe verbüsst.
Mit allem,
was auf uns niederprasselte,
und was wir durchmachen mussten.
Deshalb wäre es einfach nur fair,
dass er für uns, für die Familie,
für die Existenz, da sein könnte.
Und unsere Familie so wieder mal in
eine Normalität zurückfinden kann.
Da wir sehr hungrige Kinder haben,
muss ich da immer Gas geben
und schauen, dass ich trotzdem
ein einigermassen anständiges Essen
auf den Tisch bringe.
Das ist mir sehr wichtig.
Aber das muss eben
auch schnell gehen.
Mein Mann
kann leider nicht so gut kochen.
Obwohl es manchmal
sehr hilfreich wäre ...
... wenn er etwas vorkochen könnte.
Guten Appetit.
- Guten Appetit.
Die Kinder wissen,
dass ihr Papi verurteilt wurde
und ins Gefängnis gehen muss.
Wir mussten
die Kinder auch involvieren.
Sie kriegten das auch mit,
weil Papi in der Presse stand.
Sie wollten wissen, was los ist.
Wir schirmen sie nicht von allem ab,
sondern sprechen offen mit ihnen.
Sie wissen, was passiert.
Unsere Familie ist ein Team.
Wir halten zusammen.
Wann ist der ...
Nach der Sportwoche.
Der Skitag?
Mhm.
Im Herbst 2020
folgt ein weiterer Schock:
Der Familie Spörri
wird das Haus gekündigt.
Doch sie finden bald eine
Vierzimmerwohnung ganz in der Nähe.
Trotzdem: Die Kündigung
hat Spuren hinterlassen.
Der Moment war ganz schlimm.
Mir würde übel und ich dachte,
ich müsse mich ...
Ich müsse mich übergeben.
Es war so ein Schlag.
Und man fragt sich:
"Wohin mit der Familie?"
"Wir werden doch nichts finden
mit dieser Vorgeschichte."
Es kennen einen
dann eben doch viele Leute.
Grosse Sorgen bereiteten insbesondere
Christoph Spörris
hängige Betreibungen.
Ich brachte die Betreibungen
ja dem neuen Vermieter.
Danach sagte er: "Chapeau,
dass Sie die überhaupt bringen."
Irgendwann
werde ich es zurückzahlen.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich sage:
"Leckt mich am Arsch,
ihr werdet nie was davon sehen."
Irgendwann
möchte man wieder normal leben,
ohne die Leute
auf der Pelle zu haben.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob der etwas gross ist.
Nein, der geht.
Oder nicht.
Schaut, meine Frau.
Ich dachte nie, dass er
so kleine Möbel zusammensetzen kann.
Ich kann im Gefängnis
ein paar Möbel zusammensetzen.
Üben.
Nein, du musst lernen zu kochen.
Das weisst du.
- Ah ja, ich muss in die Küche.
Damit er
mehr in der Küche mithelfen kann,
wenn er wieder hier ist.
Inzwischen ist klar:
Der Europäische Gerichtshof
wies Christoph Spörris Beschwerde ab.
Sie ist unzulässig.
Und auch sein Gesuch,
die Haftstrafe
mit einer elektronischen Fussfessel
zu verbüssen,
wurde abgelehnt.
Er muss ins Gefängnis.
Er macht ab und zu
sarkastische Sprüche.
Irgendwie, ja ...
Z.B. wenn wir etwas eingeräumt haben
und alles gut ist,
sagt er, er wisse nicht, wie lange
er das noch geniessen könne.
Nein, es war das Sofa.
Wir haben ein neues Sofa.
Das ist so bequem. Da sagte ich,
ich könne das nur kurz geniessen.
Das ist so ein sarkastischer Spruch.
- Das tut mir schon weh. Ja.
Wenn man so viel zusammen ist,
wird es dann wohl schon schwierig,
wenn man allein auf dem Sofa sitzt.
In fünf Tagen
müsste er seine Haftstrafe antreten.
Doch er wehrt sich abermals dagegen,
legt Beschwerde
gegen den Haftantritt ein.
Er will den Entscheid im Sorgerechts-
streit um seinen Sohn abwarten.
Seine Beschwerde
führt kurz darauf tatsächlich dazu,
dass er einmal mehr
noch nicht ins Gefängnis gehen muss.
Eineinhalb Jahre später,
im März 2022:
Christoph Spörri
ist immer noch nicht im Gefängnis,
obwohl der Sorgerechtsstreit
um seinen älteren Sohn
inzwischen entschieden ist.
Das Obergericht Zug hat entschieden,
dass der Junior
bei uns in Bern bleiben kann.
Jetzt haben wir
geteiltes Sorgerecht.
Er geht, wie schon vor drei Jahren,
hier in die Schule.
Er ist glücklich.
Somit
ist die grösste Sorge erledigt.
Die Familie ist zusammen.
Doch es gibt ein neues Problem.
Es befindet sich
in dieser Schachtel:
Spörris künstliches Hüftgelenk.
Medizinische Untersuchungen zeigten,
dass sich Metallpartikel lösten,
kurz bevor Christoph Spörri seine
Haftstrafe hätte antreten müssen.
Seine Anwältin
verfasste ein dramatisches Gesuch,
um den Haftantritt zu verschieben,
damit das künstliche Hüftgelenk
ersetzt werden kann.
Wegen der fehlerhaften Prothese
würden irreparable Schäden drohen.
Die Prothese
sei eine tickende Zeitbombe
und müsse sofort ersetzt werden.
Das Gesuch hatte Erfolg:
Christoph Spörri
konnte den Haftantritt verschieben
und erhielt ein neues Hüftgelenk.
Jetzt gibt es kein Zurück.
Ich gehe ja zum ersten Mal.
Ich bin kein Dauergast im Vollzug.
Ich habe grossen Respekt davor, weil
ich nicht weiss, wie es aussieht.
Ich werde genug stark dafür sein.
Vielleicht gewöhnt man sich daran.
Zehn Tage später ist es so weit:
Tschüss.
Christoph Spörri muss ins Gefängnis.
Nur eine Sporttasche, ein Necessaire
und Krücken wegen der zurückliegenden
Hüftoperation nimmt er mit.
Im Regionalgefängnis
ist er nur für eine kurze Zeit.
Der inzwischen
53-jährige Christoph Spörri
befindet sich jetzt
in der Justizvollzugsanstalt Witzwil
im Kanton Bern.
Hier verbüsst er nun seine Strafe.
Es gibt Zimmerkontrollen,
aber das ist für mich kein Problem.
Ich bin sehr sauber und ordentlich.
Natürlich richtet man es sich
so ein, dass es einem passt.
Man ist ja länger hier.
Ich habe eine Kaffeestation.
Hier mache ich meine Müesli.
Ich lebe jetzt wieder extrem gesund.
Und ...
Ja, hier habe ich
meine Kosmetikartikel ...
Es ist eigentlich wie zu Hause.
Enthaarungscreme ...
Anfangs dachte ich,
ich würde nach zwei Jahren wie ein
Gorilla, voller Haare, rauskommen.
Dann merkte ich: Hier rasiert
und enthaart sich jeder.
Wir haben sogar Leute hier,
die einem den Bart schneiden.
Genau, also, Insassen.
Wir haben alles,
was wir draussen haben. Parfum ...
Sie parfümieren sich hier?
Ja, am Abend,
nachdem ich geduscht habe.
So hat man das Gefühl,
man sei draussen.
Draussen ist seine Familie.
Sie kann ihn regelmässig besuchen.
Täglich telefoniert er nach Hause
und schreibt Briefe.
Ich sagte von Anfang an,
dass ich jeden Tag einen Brief
nach Hause schreiben werde -
während der ganzen Haftdauer.
Alles, was passiert,
wie ich mich fühle ...
Das ist wichtig für mich,
um das zu verarbeiten.
Gab Ihr Sohn Ihnen das mal mit?
- Ja.
Das ist brutal:
"Hallo, Papi,
wir vermissen dich sehr."
"Ich hoffe,
du kannst den Antrag bald machen."
"Und nicht vergessen,
du spielst ..."
Ähm ... Sorry.
"Hallo, Papi,
wir vermissen dich sehr."
"Ich hoffe,
du kannst den Antrag bald machen."
Um rauszukommen.
"Und nicht vergessen:
Du spielst mit mir Fifa,
wenn du in den Urlaub kannst."
"Dann gehen wir YB schauen
und Barca."
"LG, Kyano."
Ja, das ist das Härteste.
Die Family.
Grüezi, Herr Buchs.
- Herr Spörri.
Dominik Buchs
ist der Vollzugsverantwortliche
von Christoph Spörri.
Er begleitet die Häftlinge
und steht für Fragen zur Verfügung.
Christoph Spörri möchte
seine Familie zu Hause besuchen
und benötigt eine Urlaubsbewilligung.
Wie stehen die Chancen,
dass das Gesuch bewilligt wird?
Je nach Vollzugsverlauf
stehen die Chancen sehr gut.
Es ist auch die Idee, dass Sie
wieder Besuche machen können,
dass Sie rausgehen können.
Aber es muss natürlich
alles stimmen.
Dann freue ich mich jetzt schon.
Ja, das ist gut.
Vorfreude ist immer gut.- Genau.
Super. Danke für die Auskunft.
- Bitte schön.
Sein Urlaubsgesuch
wurde inzwischen bewilligt.
Doch
von seiner vierjährigen Haftstrafe
hat er erst ein halbes Jahr verbüsst.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022